su rapto ha conmocionado a haití hace
una semana y media sacerdotes y monjas
fueron secuestrados y algunos de estos
sacerdotes padecen una diabetes aguda y
necesitan inyectarse insulina varias
veces al día estas personas que ya eran
muy frágiles antes de su secuestro se
encuentran ahora en una situación
precaria donde condición cree que la
iglesia católica del país lidera la
campaña para exigir su liberación
organizando un paro laboral al que se
han sumado muchas empresas escuelas y
universidades pero ya se les está
acabando la paciencia con un gobierno
que califican de incompetente tanto les
esperaremos a ver si hay alguna acción o
reacción del gobierno sobre la
liberación de los sacerdotes y las demás
personas secuestradas si no hay reacción
todo el mundo verá claramente que el
gobierno irresponsable no tiene en
contra
a las masas
ai qing un país empobrecido y
políticamente inestable ha visto un
aumento del 200 por ciento de los
secuestros durante el último año bajo
una creciente presión el presidente del
país
yo en el mois ampliamente criticado
anunció el miércoles pasado una
remodelación del gobierno al menos dos
del grupo de secuestrados son franceses
un hombre que dice ser el líder de los
raptores se puso en contacto con una
emisora de radio local y anunció que
estaban solicitando a francia el dinero
de rescate haití se independizó de
francia en 1804 antes de verse obligado
a pagar enormes indemnizaciones a su
antiguo colonizador